I am stuck in a prolonged period of
things not going my way professionally
or socially all that really is going on
well is my time management still even
after having owned up to my part in
getting here I still seem stuck in a
failure loop ok so what's being
addressed here is the prolonged period
of things not going away and and we know
that a key part of getting out of a rut
like this or a failure loop is taking
ownership of those failures of those
problems that's very important but guess
what that alone doesn't solve them at
all just saying I didn't get promoted ok
it was my fault
period that doesn't solve the fact that
you didn't get promoted I'm not getting
called back to do this other contracting
job it's my fault does that mean you get
called back no it doesn't mean anything
taking the ownership means that you
actually have to identify the problem
you know you're responsible for it and
then you actually have to solve the
problem that's what you have to do just
taking ownership of the problem doesn't
make it go away if you take ownership of
the problem you have to take ownership
of finding a solution and you have to
take ownership of implementing that
solution so this is real straightforward
now there's one little tiny part that I
want to point out which you may or may
not have noticed echo Charles and I'm
gonna point it out so pay attention to
this last sentence and the question
still even after having owned up to my
part in getting here and I still seem
stuck in a failure and failure loop what
you notice about that echo Charles if
there's another part a whole motor maybe
even parts yeah
there's multiple facets of the world
that are conspiring yeah to keep you in
this failure loop
yeah it's like that tone of when
someone's like hey I did my part
I did my job hands up you know kind of
thing though I did my job that's not my
job the other parts that are more
implied I guess now that you can uncover
in the moment it's like there's this
other job that someone else is sorta
part so this is the thing and this is
what this is what makes this very
challenging is this idea that like but
how could I possibly control this or
that how can I possibly take ownership
of the fact now this is a weak one how
can I possibly take ownership for the
fact that my boss is an idiot and fired
me hmm
how can that be my fault that he didn't
see how good I was right okay we see
what's going on there you obviously
aren't being introspective and taking a
look and saying okay this is obviously
my fault
here's what I need to change so there's
things like that where you go look
you're just not the same thing with
relationships right she broke up with me
how can I own that well maybe you look
at yourself and you see how you acted as
a partner in that relationship and if
you just want to look at that person say
it was her fault she was crazy
and oh she was it was her fault she
didn't understand how awesome I was yeah
that's not that's that you need to take
ownership of your own behavior why did
she think that now you do get to these
things where you have no control
so God asked a question a guy said my I
lost my girlfriend to opiate overdose
yeah she died how do I take ownership of
that and so I expanded that question
because that's one of those things where
you look at you know when you look at
you go how can you take ownership of
that
this person did so much drugs and it
wasn't like I liked okay I don't know
the specifics of the situation but if
you know I'm doing everything I can to
help my girlfriend and then one day I
come home and she's od'd she's dead okay
how can I say I wasn't even there right
and I let's just say I'd done everything
take her to rehab done all this stuff
and as far as I could tell she was clean
and behind my back without telling me at
least she did this right so it's almost
like okay that's as much separation as I
can get how do you take ownership in a
situation like that and so here's what I
went on to say this guy you I said this
might seem like a unique situation but
it's not because there's things that
occur in our lives that we actually
don't have any control over for instance
most horrible you your family member
someone you know gets cancer gets a
horrible terminal disease how do you
take ownership of that and the answer is
in these cases when things that are
truly beyond your control occur what you
take ownership of is how you respond to
them that's that's what you take
ownership how do you respond to you lose
your girlfriend to drugs your kid gets
cancer you get cancer something you get
this horrible disease how do you respond
to that that's what you can take
ownership of and that's what you have to
take ownership of so I guess my point in
saying that is yes there are absolutely
things that you cannot control and what
you can control is your reaction to them
when they unfold that makes sense what
scares me about this guy is he's saying
he's owned up to his part but that means
he's blaming someone else and I can the
amount of things that we have zero
control over is very small mm-hmm so
many things if we look at ourselves and
say what could I do better what could I
do different how can I make an
adjustment here how can I a
- the way this boss is how can I adapt
to the way this girl is that I'm trying
to have a relationship and by the way
that might not be the best relationship
maybe that's part of what you need to do
is take ownership of the fact that
you're addicted to this that's what he's
saying this guy here saying he's so
social on some assume he's got some
problems with his female friends right
or friends in general mm-hm
hey you didn't want to want to come
watch UFC not really I'm buying guys
that's okay we're gonna go to you know
some home is they're watching it by
myself I can't believe that you know
what's wrong with everyone else
no actually what's wrong with me mmm-hmm
now truth be told I don't want to watch
UFC with anybody else generally I want
to sit alone and watch the fights no
commentary no questions don't ask me a
question sure what was that move no I'm
watching the fight that's everyone just
be quiet a lot of times some of us we
like to demonstrate our professional
knowledge of the subject you know so
answer here you need to look at that the
reason that you're probably stuck in
this loop continually is because the
things that you're blaming on other
people take ownership of them and get
them fixed take ownership of them and
get them fixed take ownership and make
some moves take ownership and look what
you can do different that's what you
have to do